BEN CLAYTON: Hi, I'm Ben.
I'm the TO of GAPID.
This is Pascal, who's also
been working on it almost
as long as I have.
So this slide's probably a
little bit irrelevant now.
GAPID, it's an open
source, developed
in the open, trace and replay
tool for GL ES and Vulkan.
It's currently a debugger.
It can be used to diagnose
and fix many graphics
issues when developing games.
We've been using it in the field
and have found some very stupid
things that some of
the games' engines
are doing that otherwise
would be completely hidden
from the developer.
It is cross-platform.
It runs Windows,
Mac Linux, and we
can use it to trace any
debuggable Android application.
For Vulkan we actually
also support desktop,
so you can trace any Vulkan
application on Windows
or Linux, obviously not Mac.
And yes, you can go and
download it right now.
It's on GitHub, So
github.com/google/gapid,
and then you can take
a look at the releases.
So instead of just
talking about it,
it's graphics
after all, we might
as well show you some stuff.
So I'll take it over to Pascal.
PASCAL MUETSCHARD: OK, so
when we first launch it,
you will see this
welcome dialog that
lets you quickly do your most
common actions, like capturing
and tracing.
Let me see if I
can see the mouse.
The capture, trace dialog.
You choose which API
you'd like to trace.
And you trace over GL.
You can choose your
Android device.
And because we are
running out of USB ports,
we are not going to
actually do a trace.
It's also pretty boring.
You choose your APK.
You have some options.
And you can trace file.
But instead, I'll just open
trace we've taken previously.
This is a trace of one of
Google's only games, Sushi,
on Android.
Up the top, you can see the
frames that were captured.
We see some frame
previews of the frames.
This is mostly just a menu.
Let's see if we can find
something more interesting.
The beginning of
the application.
On the bottom on the left
side, you see all the commands.
And we grouped them nicely
by frames and draw calls.
And if you include debug
markers in your application.
You'll see debug markers,
which you will see right here.
We can see all the groupings.
This is tiny for me to see.
For example, you can
step through your frame
and see how it get both up.
You see all the draw calls
that are grouped here.
Of course, you can see the
actual draw calls as well.
But I might need
to just draw call.
But obviously, we
want to also show
you the rest of the
state of the GL drivers.
For example, we can
look at the geometry
that was rendered here.
This is just some leaves.
Let me pick the
shrimp sushi here.
You can see a little more
interesting geometry.
And you can, for example,
debug your normals
if they don't look OK.
You can inspect the geometry.
There was one in this draw call.
And we also allow you to
inspect all your textures.
So we see some textures
that were used.
And this also will
show you contents
of textures that are rendered
targets, which is really nice.
You normally would need
to render your shadow
map on the screen.
You can just inspect it here.
And we have some
image tools, like you
can disable channels, which is
again helpful for shadow maps.
You have different values
for different channels.
You can zoom in and inspect it.
Of course, we also
show you shaders.
And one of the things
we'd like to be able to do
is rapid prototyping.
Whenever you have an
issue to shade in.
You're adding a shade.
You save it.
You have to rebuild
the application.
Then you have to package it
up, deploy it to your device,
only just to find out that you
forgot that dot 0 or whatever.
So we allow you to edit
the shaders in place here.
So let me just paste something
in here that I've saved before.
You push your changes.
And in a few seconds,
you can see the changes
that happen and changing our
Skybox here to be a nice sunset
red.
You can see that it has
changed on all frames.
We've changed our little
sky box to be nice and red.
We tracked the entire
state of the GL drivers,
so you can inspect at
any point in your trace.
If you see an
issue, and you want
to know what was the plan
state at this point in trace,
you can go in and
inspect the trace.
You can see the plane
state, for example,
right here for frame box here.
You can see all the
values that you've set.
Oh, this should be
something different.
We also have the beginning
of a reporting system
that tracks errors, for example.
Jail errors-- it does a
jail error doing a trace.
We'll show it here, for example.
You can quickly
go to the command
and see this get integer has
an interesting identifier that
doesn't exist.
And we're also planning
on other things
that we can detect in
your trace and give you
actionable feedback on how
you can improve your day.
I think that covers
about most of it.
BEN CLAYTON: Did
you try the memory?
PASCAL MUETSCHARD: Obviously,
for some commands, like--
let's just find something
like GL uniform.
It's not exactly very
interesting to see the memory
pointer.
So we also obviously
track the memory.
And you can see what
memory was passed.
And you can format it
in the [INAUDIBLE]..
So here, you can
see the matrix that
was passed into this uniform.
BEN CLAYTON: The memory
is the sort of power tool.
But for any particular
command that you select,
you can see all
of the memory that
was read or written
by the command
at that point in the trace.
Just being handy for sort
of off-by-one errors.
So yeah, that's pretty much
the tool at the moment.
A couple of other things.
He's put multiple
context for GL.
The bar at the top,
it, by default,
selects what we consider
the most relevant context
for the particular game.
But for a lot of
the engines, there's
multiple contexts
that are spun up.
So you can look between them.
As an option as well for an
interleaved context mode,
so that you can
see how the context
of talking to each of them.
But yeah, that's pretty
much what we have right now.
If there's any
questions, by the way,
please feel free to interrupt.
PASCAL MUETSCHARD: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is there a high
resolution CPU timestamp
on this?
Sometimes it's nice to know what
your codes are doing CPU side
when it's building the frame.
BEN CLAYTON: Currently, no.
We did want to put extra
metadata in, like, time stamp
information.
We're kind of on the fence
about the usefulness of that.
Because when you do take
trace, times are skewed.
So having real-time information
can be a little bit deceptive.
But things like stack
trace information
would be particularly useful.
Just seeing a particular
draw call is bad.
Where did that come from?
So yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BEN CLAYTON: Again, if you
have these suggestions,
please forward them to us.
And we will act upon them.
AUDIENCE: Does the frame rate
view show the current render
target that's bound,
or is it showing what's
going to be the back buffer?
The frame buffer we use
shows what is currently
abound at that point in a trace.
BEN CLAYTON: If you have
post effects and things that
are going on off screen,
you can debug all of them.
AUDIENCE: Maybe I missed it.
What's the requirement
for GPU and the Android OS
supported now?
Does it work on all GPUs,
which Android versions?
BEN CLAYTON: OK, so in theory,
it shouldn't really matter.
The way that we
intercept at the moment
is by patching the driver.
And there are some limitations
on what we can patch.
So we require a
certain number of bytes
of instruction per function
we're trying to tamper with.
And on certain
drivers, there are
functions that are too short.
Coming up in a new version of
Android and coming to you soon
is [INAUDIBLE] OS support.
So we won't be doing this
nasty driver patching.
We will actually
have hooks in the OS.
So we can trace anything.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Is frame buffer [INAUDIBLE]
on pixel [INAUDIBLE] extension
support for--
BEN CLAYTON: We can examine
depth at the moment.
We haven't got a
view for stencil.
But we'll be working
on that soon.
AUDIENCE: That's
pretty useful for us.
BEN CLAYTON: So speaking
of what we're doing--
before that, just to
mention that the tool
is pretty modular.
We have all of the
bulk of the smarts
in one particular process.
And the UI isn't actually
tied into that at all.
We have an RPC interface, the
UI users to talk to the server.
And we have another
tool that we actually
ship when you download it.
It's called GAPID.
And it actually exposes a lot
of the same functionality.
It's been really useful
for us developing.
You can use it to examine
commands, states, frames,
and use that to try and find
GL errors or Vulkan issues.
And we see a lot of value in
this in automated testing.
You can take trace.
You can use the
command line tools
as part of your nightly
builds, for example, and find
issues in your application that
would otherwise go missing.
So just to an
example, I'm not going
to type up the command line.
But given the same trace
that we were just demoing,
you can get a screenshot
at any particular point.
We also have the ability
to create an MP4 video
of whatever you have.
There's also another
mode that we have,
where we will capture the frame
buffer while we're tracing.
And then when we come
to do a validate,
we can actually check
that the replay matched.
When we have one
device replay going,
that can be particularly useful
for variations between drivers,
for example.
And my slide failed.
Yay.
So the current work that
we're doing at the moment,
for those of you
that may have tried
GAPID already, you may
have been disappointed
with performance of the tool.
We are fully aware that it
isn't as fast as it should be.
And it takes up too much memory.
So this is our number
one thing that we're
working on right now--
make it faster.
Make it less resource-hungry.
Mid-execution
capture for GL ES is
what we've heard people
want lots and lots.
So we're going to try and
get that out very soon.
And on device replay--
as we briefly mentioned.
I've virtually used up all
the USB ports on this machine.
The replay for GL ES is
being done on this machine.
So we translate from GL ES
to desktop GL for replay.
We've taken that about
as far as we can.
Apple refused to push GL drivers
any further than they are.
We're now at the state
that GL ES is actually
exceeding desktop GL, the base
port, so on desktop replay,
just through translation,
is actually becoming
difficult to impossible.
For Vulkan, same thing--
performance.
We also want to get
the validation there
as part of the report.
So you don't have to
have the layers in when
you take a trace.
And you get the same
information out.
And the final one is an improved
UI for visualizing Vulkan data.
Vulkan is a very different
beast from GL ES.
Is not immediate mode.
You've got command buffers.
Trying to display things as
a linear sequence of calls
is one way of doing it.
But it isn't the best
way that we feel.
So we're doing a lot of
research at the moment
in how to better visualize
these new graphics
APIs, where you have more of
a graph representation maybe.
So after that, we have a large
collection of ideas of things
that we want to do.
But we want to get
feedback from you
on where we should be
investing our time.
I've been leading this project
for a number of years now.
And as a teenager, I always used
to play RTS games for too much.
So tech trees are
kind of the way
that I visualize my job in
that there are many things
that I could be doing
and certain things unlock
other things.
And so the rest of
these slides are
going to be going through some
of the things that we can do
and how I categorize them
in my crazy gamey brain.
There is a questionnaire
that you can fill in
as we're going through this.
It might be helpful
to play along,
just so that you'd
know what I'm talking
about when you have a question.
If you don't want
to, that's fine.
Won't hold it against me.
But if you can open
that, please go ahead.
And the slides will
relate to the questions
that come through.
Cool.
PASCAL MUETSCHARD:
There's a question.
BEN CLAYTON: Question?
AUDIENCE: Is there any timeline
for a graphics profiler
for the GPU?
PASCAL MUETSCHARD: Timeline?
We'll see what the
feedback is from today.
We might be able to get
a timeline from that.
Cool.
So the first group
is statistics.
I classify things that
don't involve profiling
but still have meaningful
values under this group.
So the simplest one, which we
probably should have by now,
is the sort of x per y stuff.
So this is number of
draw calls per frame
is the most obvious one.
Doing 2,000 draw
calls on a device that
can only cope with
a few hundred,
you're going to have a bad time.
Examples of this are
obviously draws per frame,
vertices per draw,
triangles per whatever,
estimates of memory
usage as well, like,
number of makes of
textures that you have.
We also want to come up with
some sort of device budgets.
Part of my work
over the last year
has been going out
to games' companies
and trying to help them
get the games reaching 60.
Based on the x per
y thing, the number
of titles that are
being developed
without any kind of
reasonable guidelines
on how many draw
call that you should
be making for a
particular device
is a little bit depressing.
We could offer up
some sort of data
that, for a particular
flagship device,
we recommend that you submit x
number of vertices per frame,
for example.
We could have inside
GAPID automatic knowledge
of a collection of
different devices
and give you warnings if
it notices that you're
way outside those budgets.
FrameBuffer
visualizations-- these
are things like number of
overdraws that you're doing.
We can also include
things in here
like highlighting the fragments
that may have failed a depth
test, which could
be a good thing
or displaying the frame
by shader program,
for example, which is
a great way of knowing
where you should be looking
at optimizing your shaders.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PASCAL MUETSCHARD: Yeah,
overdraw is part of that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PASCAL MUETSCHARD: It's coming.
Shader static analysis--
this is a tricky one.
It would have to be a sort
of finger in the air one.
Because there's
many different GPUs
out there, many intermediate
layers between your shader code
and actually what the shader is
doing, the hardware is doing.
But, yeah, we can come up with
some rough estimates of number
of ALU ops through
text, for example,
which can be helpful in just
getting a hand-wavy estimate
of what your shaders are doing.
Profiling-- big
feature request here.
First thing that people think
of is frame and draw, counters,
I've said.
But frame and draw
time would be great.
Unfortunately, tiled
architectures make draw
call times very difficult.
We've got a few ideas on we
might be able to come up with
some data that would be useful.
But knowing what your
frame rate is like,
or knowing how long
certain things are taking
is definitely something
that we want to do.
If we can also get hardware
counters from the IHVs,
we would like to try and massage
those huge seas of hardware
counters that nobody really
understands into something
meaningful, so that we can
tell you how much time you're
spending doing [INAUDIBLE]
fetches, how much time you're
cache messing, for example.
Something that a
lot of the IHV tools
offer over things like draw call
times is relative shader costs.
So while their tools may not
be able to tell you exactly how
long a single draw call took,
they take more of the approach
that these are all the shader
programs that you have.
And this particular one
actually takes 30% of your time.
So it's where you
should be optimizing.
This is something that
I think is very valuable
and we should definitely have.
Assuming that we get
the first two done,
we would love to have
metrics-driven suggestions.
So if you've used other
tools before in the past,
they often suggest,
have you thought
about changing you vertex
format so that you [INAUDIBLE]
as opposed to having
them separate?
These are things that
we would like the tool
to actually go and do for you.
If we have a bunch of patterns
that the tool can actually
detect, apply them to
your trace and time them,
we can offer a
sorted list of things
that you could do to optimize
your gain ordered by impact.
I understand that
games' developers,
their time is precious.
You don't want to be
spending three days trying
to optimize something to get
half a percent improvement.
If we can show you that
doing this one thing
will save you 10% of your
time, we should do it.
Another thing that's
often forgotten
is power usage and thermals.
It's really important.
So if we're going to
give you any profiling
information about
timing, we should also
be looking at how much
power you are using
and see if there's
anything that we can
do to suggest reducing them.
Shader debugging-- being able to
click on a vertex or a fragment
in your FrameBuffer and
have single-line stepping.
So this is pretty bug basic.
We want to be able to let you
step forwards and backwards,
have a watch window, see all
the values as you go along.
There's a big question
here as well about
whether you would
value more a simulation
versus real hardware.
There are pros and cons to both.
If you're trying
to debug something,
and you're getting black pixel,
and it's a driver or hardware
issue, then, obviously, having
a reference form of that
might prove to you that there
actually is a hardware issue.
Whereas, trying to pull back
from the actual hardware
might give you skewed
results in the same way.
Pixel history-- it's kind
of part of the debugging,
but clicking on the
FrameBuffer, seeing
all of the draws that
influence the color,
or depth, or stencil.
I may be including or
excluding ones that
have since been overwritten.
A table of shader
ins and outs-- this
is more common for vertex forms.
If you've got one
crazy vertex that's
half a mile across
the screen, you
can identify that single thing,
and then go and debug it,
and figure out why you've
got [INAUDIBLE] or something.
And something else
that we thought
about it would be very
nice is, if you're
debugging a particular shader,
highlighting the inputs
and outputs.
So if you've got
textures, for example,
that you're sampling
in your shaders,
actually highlighting
the fragments that
are involved in that
particular shader [INAUDIBLE]..
Assuming we can do it, it
would also be very nice
if you had an isotropic
filtering showing
all of the fragments that
are actually being used.
And then finally, we come
onto the reference restorizer.
So touching a
problem of our saying
that we have taken the
desktop replay about as
far as I think we can take it.
We're now looking
at alternatives.
So a reference restorizer
could be very useful
for other things, as well as
having a guaranteed replay
that you can do on
your host machine.
Now the first one
is that we know
the devices do have issues.
Drivers can be buggy.
Hardware can actually be faulty.
We really want to
hear about this.
We can't stress enough
how much we want
to hear about broken drivers.
We know that people
are having a bad time.
But we have to go out and ask
you a lot about your stories.
So if you had a trace, and
you take it, and you are idle,
we think that we could do
a replay in the background
with the reference restorizer.
And after, you
checked that what you
are getting replayed
on the device
matches what we
think it should be.
And if they are not the
same, we can offer you
a one-click reporter bug.
That gives us an exact repro
that we can give to the driver
teams to fix that.
So it would be a nice way
for the Android ecosystem
to be better all around.
GL ES and Vulkan,
they are specs that
have hand-wavy aspects to it,
especially around floating
point precision and sampling.
If we have a
reference restorizer,
we think that
there'll be value here
in having some knobs
that you can fiddle with
to basically compare
how things would look
on different hardware specs.
So the floating point
precision is the classic one.
If you load your
floating point precision,
do your shaders then suddenly
start dividing by zero.
This is something that
happens and something
that maybe we could catch
for you automatically
in a [INAUDIBLE].
On-host replay-- we've
got it for GL ES.
We would like it
for Vulkan as well.
Reference restorizer makes
that definitely possible
and more solid than what
we have at the moment.
And then finally, the
automated testing things.
This kind of goes back
to the GAPID tool.
If you have a ref
rest, and you've
got, say, nightly builds
that you're doing,
you could just basically
have GAPID automatically
take a trace of your game.
Make sure that you've got no
bad usage of the graphics' APIs.
And you can also use
it to get a reference
video of what the game
should be looking like.
And also use the
toolings to actually get
videos across the different
devices that you care about
and potentially flag them
as issues as they pop up,
as opposed to in the
last week of getting
the game out the door.
So that was a lot
of stuff that I just
covered very, very quickly.
If there were things that
I've missed here and you think
are very valuable, please,
please, please, let us know.
And that's it.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: You talked
about the power profiling.
BEN CLAYTON: Sorry, mic for him.
AUDIENCE: You just
mentioned power profiling.
Could you elaborate?
BEN CLAYTON: It's still very
much in research at the moment.
But the idea is that we
could have the ability
to replay the same
frame repeatedly.
And if we had hardware support
for actually seeing the drain
and monitoring the
thermals, we can at least
come up with a, if you keep
on having your game render
something similar to this
particular frame, this
is the kind of characteristics
that you're going to have
on the battery and thermals.
And any of the heuristics
that we have for optimization,
we can also try that as well.
It might be something that you
would have to run overnight
to try and get stable results.
But it's better
than weeks and weeks
of poking around yourself.
AUDIENCE: Can you put the URL
back up for the questionnaire?
BEN CLAYTON: Sure.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: For the power
and thermals, is there
going to be any way
to tie that back
to the core frequencies
and the CPU usage,
so you can see
whether or not there's
a trade-off between your
submission of the call
time versus the actual GPU time?
BEN CLAYTON: Great suggestion.
Yeah, maybe.
These are things that we
have briefly looked at.
We haven't started
development on.
So yeah, if that's valuable.